nathan is with us nathan is in
cincinnati ohio
hi nathan welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi how are y'all doing better than i
deserve what's up
all right so uh i have about
thirty two thousand dollars in that my
wife and i uh i make about thirty
thousand dollars a year
uh she stays home and takes care of our
two-year-old and one month old um and
about 20 almost 27 000 of my
32 is a car that i uh
stupidly bought and
i am trying to figure out how to get rid
of it um
i have listened to listen to you for a
couple months now
um and uh i'm
i can get about 20 grand out of it uh
private party so
um i owe 26 7 on it
um and i'm i guess i'm trying to i'm
having a hard time
um figuring out how uh to get the money
borrowed um i've called a lot of my
local banks and credit unions
and i have nothing to
leverage so they're having a hard time
agreeing to lend me the difference um so
i'm just kind of stuck
who's the current loan with uh toyota
financial
yeah that's going to be no help yeah
young brother you got your hands full
don't you
little babies and that hanging around
your neck you can't breathe i'm sorry
wow what a hard time and what a hard
place
well we have to get rid of that deficit
in order to get the title to give it to
the buyer
when they pay you 20 000 for the car
right
yes sir and so that means we have a 7
000
problem plus or minus now we either make
that an income very quickly with 18
extra jobs
and or we put some of it on a credit
card i would rather you have seven
thousand dollars in credit card debt
than twenty seven thousand dollar car
loan
okay because a lot easier to pay off
yes sir and so if you go get a couple
credit cards and six jobs
and between the two you scrape up seven
thousand bucks and then you get the car
sold
that's how we're gonna have to do it uh
are you a member of a credit union
um i guess technically yeah i haven't
been active with them
in quite a while but i'm technically a
member of navy federal credit union
yeah do they have a local branch
um not real close i actually just got
back into my account for the first time
in about two years the other day
so i i them i have not talked to about
it um but
anytime you're trying to do something
like this if you can sit down in person
versus over the phone you said you'd
call them all and some of them aren't
open and they're not meeting in person i
understand that
but if there's an opportunity you got a
better when you're making up when you're
making an
application for a loan you're selling
someone on loaning you money
and a sale in person is always easier
and more effective
than a sale over the phone or by email
or
text or anything else so if you can get
in front of them that'll be helpful
and i'd rather you have a personal loan
than anything we've discussed
but what do you do for a living i
am um easily put a stack lumber
um i have an opportunity upcoming uh to
go to
school um to be uh it'll be fully uh
funded by my
employer and once i get back from school
i'll get i'll go from making 14.50 to
close to 20 bucks a night right at 20
an hour what kind of school would you go
to
it's lumber grading school in memphis by
the uh nhla national park
and how long does that take uh seven
weeks
or a close eight oh that sounds like a
wonderful idea
yes sir yeah i would do that as quickly
as i could
um and that's a trade that's going to
have a lot of demand
because lumber uh as you already know
has skyrocketed
and so the value of someone who knows
how to grade it is going to go up
nothing but
up that's a wonderful wonderful vo tech
position
it's hard work but you're not afraid of
hard work
so let's lean it let's lean in on
getting that school done
before you go i want you you're working
40 hours right
uh about 50. yep yeah before you go i
want to kick it on up to about 70 or 80
with side jobs any side job you can get
doing anything
building decks anywhere you can make
wherever you make the most money as a
side job
and start chunking that down on that car
because we can get the thing just paid
down seven thousand
i mean let's say you made 1500 a month
at your side job
which would be like delivering pizzas
every night as an example yes
okay that's no fun but fifteen hundred
times three
is forty five hundred times four months
is six thousand we're almost there
and so you know if you did this for
three or four months and got the hat
got the car paid down where you can get
rid of it and or
borrow some money to get rid of it then
when you go off to school the car
payment's not there
oh that would be incredible yeah we
would uh we'd be cutting our um
monthly expenses close to in half
because my wife uh
will either come with me or go back to
south carolina and stay with her family
uh so you would be cutting our expenses
you know
well in half yeah for just for that
seven weeks
yes sir and if you got rid of the car
it'd be more than that
absolutely yeah so i'm gonna prescribe
uh you know
apply for some credit cards try to get a
in-person meeting with navy federal
um anything she can do as a side with
the two babies at home i don't know what
that would be but just something she can
do from home obviously
for any kind of income ebaying used
clothes
i don't care people do all kinds of
stuff when they get up against the wall
and dude you guys are up against the
wall i'm so sorry you're facing all this
we're going to help you i'm also going
to put you in our school it's called
ramsay plus
with financial peace university and
you're not afraid of hard work you're
not looking for the government to fix
your life so i'm going to help you for
free
i'm going to pay for the whole thing for
a year and i want you and your wife to
go through
every single class of financial peace
university and once you get on that
every dollar budget
get dialed in get in there and ask a
coach some of them will walk you through
the whole process of getting out from
under this car the rest of the way
let's get rid of that car let's get in
school and
um one year from the day you're going to
be in an absolutely different position
and uh you're a tough young dude man and
you've got a lot on your plate right now
and we're going to be here for you you
hold on and kelly will pick up